in an age of concern about climate
change some people have become opposed
to the very idea of having children
congressman Alexandria Acacio Cortez is
warning that it could be immoral to have
kids our planet is going to be disaster
if we don't turn the ship around and so
it's basically like there's scientific
consensus that the lives of children are
going to be very difficult and it does
lead I think young people to have a
legitimate question you know should is
it okay to still have children some
people decided that no it is not okay to
have children why pepino is a co-founder
of birth strike it's a group people who
are refusing to have children in order
to resist climate change and she joins
us anyway thanks very much for coming on
I think this story makes me sad I'm I'm
not here to attack you I want to take
what you're saying seriously but I'm not
sure I understand why you're choosing
not to have children so I would be
grateful if you tell us
sure and yeah thank you for asking
because a lot of people are getting a
little bit confused about what we're
trying to do here birth strike isn't
about trying to stop other people from
having children we feel too afraid to
have kids because we feel that we're
heading towards civilization breakdown
as a result of the environmental crisis
and the sort of mismanagement or
political inertia over dealing with it
does that make sense it does make sense
it's a sadder answer even than I
imagined I mean because there are a lot
of people who argue that nobody should
have kids that's what argument you're
basically saying the species is over
it's hopeless we should in effect as a
group ended commit suicide well I think
where we are now is incredibly
frightening and what I discovered when I
made the decision and started talking
about it too are the young women around
me was that we felt like we'd lost faith
in the system and the authorities
because they weren't really dealing with
this situation they weren't managing the
threats properly that we've been we've
been told about so yes it is
sad but at the same time best strike
itself as a is a hopeful act what we're
trying to say is come on we've got two
options you know we either unite
collectively behind action on this
immediately because we're already
heading towards the collapse or we
consign ourselves to I mean it sounds
crazy but it's true extinction so what
makes me so sad is this is a metaphor
for the broader West's loss of the will
to live which is so obvious everywhere
you turn I wonder though did it occur to
you and I I'm not disagreeing with your
forecast that there are bumpy times
ahead that's obvious but wouldn't it be
a mark of defiance maybe part of the
solution to have a bunch of smart decent
children who might solve these problems
yeah I totally understand that point of
view and and there's been people in my
life who are very aware of the severity
of what we're heading to who have made
that decision and they've they've said
you know it's the kind of most hopeful
act that you could you could you could
take is to have a child in these times
and I do respect that I do respect that
what if you were to fly to Africa
tonight and just do a tour a lot of
dozens of course scores of countries in
Africa but if you were to just pick five
and meet ten people in each on the
street and explain what you're doing
what do you think the reaction would be
I have no idea do you think people
outside the West can understand this do
you think there's any other civilization
that has decided things are so hopeless
we we must all die I really don't know I
I wouldn't be able to say do you do you
I mean is this something you've thought
for a long time or tell us how were you
you were convinced that things are so
bad that you shouldn't reproduce well
yeah I think that I mean I've been
concerned about the environment for a
long time but I you know I got
distracted by
my career and and just being a young
person and living the life that I saw
other people on television living and
that seemed to be the right thing to do
and then the last few years I just kept
reading more and more things and last
year with the IPCC report that came out
and then the Met report and things have
been corroborated by pretty much 99% of
the scientific community if not all sane
scientists it's pretty incontrovertible
now it's so what I don't mean this as
criticism I mean it sincerely what
you're describing sounds very much like
a religious conversion does and the life
you're living seems almost a monastic
life is that correct yeah a monastic
life I don't think no you should come
and hang out with your family for the
cause of children around me and I'm
fighting for them really this is my way
of saying come on Humanity we've got two
options we're either going to commit
some kind of species suicide by ignoring
the issue because we're too afraid of
the change or something or we're going
to unite together and at least try and
manage some of the collapse that's
predicted in a sensible and rational way
but look we are living and we just met
it's a little early for me to be giving
you advice but I just want to end with
this I think you should have children I
think they solve a lot of problems and
put things in perspective you seem like
a nice time there's always that like
they thank you so much for joining us
tonight thank you for having me